you know it sounds like this I really
wish I used video clips because that
clip of Helen Lovejoy just hysterically
opining think of the children would just
be perfect hello there everybody so we
have arrived at this month's planned
video on the topic of lgbtq+
representation which means we're gonna
swap the look out really quick and your
reminder in case you're new around these
parts I have a fluid sense of gender
which I do like to express a little bit
more cleanly in these videos and this
one's gonna be a little bit different
because instead of talking about an
element of representation or
representation in a specific franchise
i'ma said I'm gonna flip it around I'm
gonna focus on the ways in which
representation is perceived and accepted
or not accepted as is often the case now
the reason I'm bringing this up is
partly is a little bit of a follow up to
the video from a few months back that I
did on Harry Potter that video talked
about the lack of lgbtq+ representation
in that franchise as well as touching on
a few others and I don't really want to
rehash the points that I made in that
video you can feel free to check it out
there'll be a little link up in the
corner assuming I remember to do it but
I noticed that there were a few things
that came up continuously in the
comments now some of them I addressed
already in another video but one of the
ones that I saw a lot was some variant
of these books these stories are for
kids and that kind of material is just
not appropriate yes it's the good old
think of the children argument
now I actually want to be careful about
the way that I talk about this because
look let's be blunt about it sometimes
this argument is a very deliberate
smokescreen it is a more acceptable
argument than the one that some people
want to be making and they know that
because there are people out there still
who very firmly believe that being
anything other than both heterosexual
and cisgender is an inherently wrong
wicked or obscene thing and I'm not
going to talk about people who believe
that I'll say what I've said in previous
videos I I have nothing to say to them
it's not because I'm on some high horse
where I feel like I'm above them but
there really isn't much for us to say to
each other that isn't just a waste of
everybody's time we're never gonna agree
on the basic premise for a debate
so instead talking about this this whole
thing the whole idea of that shouldn't
be in the children's book when it comes
to lgbtq+ representation I'm aiming this
discussion more people who seem to be a
bit torn about it you know folks maybe
who aren't arguing for withholding
rights from lgbtq+ people or anything
like that but they still find themselves
squeamish about the idea of that kind of
representation in media specifically
aimed at kids though I mean naturally
anybody who firmly knows their stance on
either side of this debate you can feel
free to stick around just know we're
sort of my focus in my intent is so I'm
also largely gonna focus specifically on
homosexuality as opposed to the full
LGBTQ plus spectrum because I do
actually think that acquainting children
with concepts of people being
transgender non-binary gender fluid and
so forth is it kind of has its own set
of hurdles and those are similar but
don't quite line up with what I'm gonna
be focusing on in this video so the
first question for me becomes why is it
fairly common to feel uncomfortable
about children seeing or being talked to
about homosexuality at all because I
mean frankly that discomfort it's not
logical and you know I'm not even going
to address compared to the level of
violence that accepts that is acceptable
and things that are for kids
I'm limit
discussion to depictions of sexuality
not sex but sexuality because every time
a male character is shown to have so
much as a crush on a female character or
vice versa that is a depiction of
sexuality heterosexuality to be specific
so again unless you believe that
homosexuality is inherently wrong then
depicting it should be no more offensive
than heterosexuality being presented in
kids films and that's all over the darn
things and I for one don't recall
anybody calling for boycotts or crying
what about children over this or this or
this
folks are fine with this this and this
no concerns about this this or this
apparently this this or this totally
fine as is this this and this
everything's peachy here here and of
course here even though she's asleep
unable to give consent to this man who
she's literally never met so oh that's
fine in general and if we're talking
Harry Potter specifically all of this
is totally cool for kids but making this
a caning couple would be a step too far
now that's me making biological argument
but I also want to get past the logic
because what I'm talking about
ultimately our emotional responses and
emotional responses by their nature are
not inherently logical so as fun and
cathartic as that little exercise was it
doesn't do much to look at the problem
because pointing out that a feeling is
inconsistent or not backed up by data or
is hypocritical doesn't actually make
that feeling go away so why do so many
of us get squeamish about kids seeing
same-sex couples I think one of the
biggest things it's just the fact that
societally we're still shaking off
generations worth of ingrained anti-gay
sentiments and as much as we might like
to go yes I do believe that homosexuals
are people I'm so woke that doesn't
instantly erase all the learned behavior
we've had up to that point which is
telling you otherwise I mean you can be
woke as hell and still find yourself
uncomfortable at two guys holding hands
that doesn't make you a bad person it
just means that this stuff runs deeper
than just your conscious understanding
that it's there and that's true of all
of us I mean that's true of me I've been
working through my own BS presumptions
about people just like anybody else
hopefully this problem will get better
with time as you make an effort to not
teach these presumptions to our own kids
but that's that's gradual stuff so for
people who are currently raising kids or
have done so in the past in other words
people my age and older there's still a
lot that we've got so just cluttering up
our headspace
is about all of this so what are some of
those presumptions that are still
holding on for today's parents well
there's the underlying message that
anything that isn't heterosexual and
cisgender is simply abnormal an abnormal
can be a weird thing because strictly
speaking it just means not typical not
usual and not the most common option but
it's a word and a concept that carries
with it a great deal of negative
connotations there is a lot of baggage
in the idea of abnormal and it's
unlikely that anybody would use that
word to describe a US citizen who's
watching broadcast soccer I mean that is
abnormal statistically speaking they're
in the minority but people wouldn't use
that term because the term carries
negative connotations yet we will use
that term and things like it for
deviations from heterosexual cisgender
and I think part of that is a fear of
going against nature because if you
contextualize sex for its biological
purpose then homosexuality makes no
sense because suddenly it's not
fulfilling the purpose that sex should
have from a strictly biological
perspective and that adds another layer
to the perceived wrongness of it even
though the reality is that sex in human
society is and always has been about
much more than the simple need to
propagate the species but then there's
the other long-feared aspects of
homosexuality like the fear of
recruiting now this was a big one for a
long time and it still persists overtly
in some areas the idea that homosexuals
are actively seeking to turn
heterosexuals into one of their own and
that fear is most frequently bought
brought up in regards to children that
is why so much anti-gay propaganda
paints homosexuals gay men especially as
pedophiles
they're coming for your kids to turn
them into the their own and grow their
numbers and even if you don't
consciously believe that I think it's a
drum that was banked for so loud and so
long there's a fair number of people who
in the back of their minds can't help
but think okay it's not that I think
these are recruiting kids but I mean
maybe just to be safe we don't expose
the kids to it because to be frank about
it being a parent it makes you paranoid
and I know because I'll remind you I've
got a kid of my own as a parent you over
examine everything for how it could
possibly damage hurt or otherwise screw
up your kid and much like if you go on
the internet and look up any medical
symptom eventually you'll come to the
conclusion that you must have cancer
because that's the most extreme
possibility if you start thinking about
what your kid takes in from their shows
movies video games whatever you can
imagine the worst possible scenario and
suddenly something innocent feels a bit
less so in addition I think many folks
my age and older we think back to our
own experiences of learning what
homosexuality was now I can't speak for
everybody but I can talk for myself that
basically came up in sex ed class or you
know whatever your equivalent of that
was which meant that the focus when I
first learned about it was on the
physical mechanics and way less on the
emotional bond again not speaking for
anybody else but I do suspect that most
folks my age were presented with the
idea of homosexuality as a guy loves
another guy but instead with gay guys do
it in the bus and that's a weird way to
learn about attraction and I honestly
think it's a big part of the inherent
squeamishness that so many people have
they think gays in
kids media and they think oh my god I'm
gonna have to explain but stuff to my
kid I think that's the underlying buried
stuff that's doing some of the driving
when it comes to this knee-jerk
squeamishness even though though of
course you don't have to explain that
back to your kid any more than you have
to explain straight sex to your
four-year-old because they saw Ariel
kiss Prince Erik even if a kid is
confused the answer is simple yes boys
can love boys girls can love girls hey
some even love both boys and girls
that's it that's the extent of what you
actually need to bring kids up to speed
on you don't need to diagram the
mechanics out for them and let let's get
real here for a second if your child has
access to the Internet they already know
the mechanics so whatever you think
you're shielding them from sorry hey
you've already lost and I think it's
about the fact that in general as a
society we're able to think about
heterosexual relationships without our
brains leaping in all the way to
extrapolating to actual sex
whereas we seem to be unable to think
about homosexual relationships but I
just flat out thinking about that kind
of sex as well and nobody wants to talk
to other kids about sex I don't care how
cool a parent you are nobody is actually
looking forward to that conversation and
our inability to think about gay people
without also thinking about gay sex
might just be the hang-up that this all
comes back to and again I I get it I
really do I I understand the desire to
protect your kids and keeping an eye out
for everything they could possibly go
wrong
but when it comes to things like
reaction to lgbtq+ people that I think
much more than a lot of other stuff is
that's a that's a really learned
behavior the less weirdness you inject
into it the less they're gonna have then
if we're lucky they'll be even less
weirdness with their kids and we can get
this thing Don I'd like to see it more
or less fade in my lifetime but I'd I
mean let's be realistic so I do get it I
do get the squeamishness but think about
what it is that actually makes you
uncomfortable about the idea of gay
people in kids media because I think for
at least some people it's because
they're not recognizing that part of
their brain isn't really thinking gay
people in children's media is thinking J
sex in children's media which of course
isn't the reality but the thing is even
heterosexual good old-fashioned straight
sex took a while in terms of media
representation if you're not familiar
with the Hays Code in Hollywood
you couldn't even show a married couple
in the same bed and I got like forget a
sex scene but just like getting into bed
to go to sleep one of my favorite movie
series is the Thin Man series and and
the characters who are who have amazing
romantic chemistry and are so obviously
in love with each other and they're
adorable and then getting these separate
twin beds it's ridiculous but there was
a fear that even that tiny
acknowledgment that they share a bed oh
well if they share a bed
what are they able to do together in
that bed oh my god protected them
citizens protect the children from any
horrible depiction of two people laying
in a bed together under a blanket in
full pajamas that did not cause of any
sort of breakdown of the moral fiber
when we got over that and stopped doing
that and it's not gonna cause a massive
breakdown in the moral fiber societally
or of your kid individually if you show
two boys holding hands or a couple of
girls or a girl kissing another girl on
the cheek I mean I'm talking about
children's media so I'm talking about
relatively innocent stuff here halves
just have somebody crush on the same
gender it's okay like really it is so I
think I'll wrap up there I hope I made
my point okay and I had a lot to kind of
wrap into that but wrap it up there
think of the children what are your
thoughts on it whatever they are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it there's a whole bunch of stuff
you can do you can like and subscribe a
patreon check it out on there's buttons
and links and stuff check it out down
below if you feel like it but you know
what if you don't
hey I can't tell you what to do because
you are the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]